i mean when this came your way
how much were you actually told about
the story and your character because
he seems to be someone we really kind of
have the least backstory on
yeah i mean to be honest when i when i
first got the
the sides the audition sides um i didn't
have much to go off of other than the
fact that
i was david e kelly it was um
you know leanne moriarty uh so you know
the people behind big little eyes and
and the undoing and all that stuff and
also nicole kidman nicole kidman and
melissa mccarthy so
i know that it was of high caliber i
know that i had to bring my a game if
anything
um but yeah i was privy to not a lot of
information
um so i started to get into the book
started to try and get some more
information through that and
and that gave me a bit of an anger in
regards to what i could
form yao into when did you feel like you
had a real sense of him
and who he was did i
ever um uh i think
um i think when i finally was able to
to kind of sit down and talk with uh the
trio
to put it that way um nicole who plays
masha and tiffany
who plays delilah once we got to really
sit down together
i think it was literally on the day
that we got together that morning of to
really sit down and talk about our
dynamic and
and figure out our um our anchors and
our goals i was i was really able to
hone in on on yell and kind of the the
purpose of tranquil
what do each of those women mean and
represent to him
oh that's a great question um so yao is
definitely in this triangle um and he's
pulled in two different directions
he's pulled towards the path of purpose
and and devotion
with with masha um but he's also pulled
toward
uh common sense and and um being more
down to earth and and safety and love
with
with delilah so he's yeah it's a bit of
a tug and war a tug of war
uh some internal conflict that he's
dealing with while he has to
keep a straight face for for all the
nine perfect strangers
what was it like working with those two
women how how did they
what were they like a scene partners how
did they compare in their approach to
this whole weird dynamic between you
guys
i mean the first thing that comes to
mind the word that comes to mind is is
open
you know uh you know at the end of the
day whether it be talking about their
acting or
or just them as human beings um you know
they're just very open
uh and i felt very safe with both of
them because
i don't know how far you got into the
series and don't want to spoil anything
but we do have some pretty intimate
moments
yeah um and i felt comfortable doing
that with them and that's
the biggest thing that you can hope for
and a partner is that they're
they're open to to doing and taking
to doing uh certain things that that
could be risky
in a sense but still feel safe did you
work with an intimacy coordinator on
this was that something that was also
available to you
we absolutely did yeah um and
she i really am beating myself for not
remembering her name but she is
incredibly helpful in regards to uh
trying to figure out
how to uh
in trying to really push that
uh sexual intimacy on screen without
being overtly sexual um you know it's
not really about the
the act of it but the uh the notion or
the mystery of it that
that she really helped us with with
honing pony with
honing into did you have a
favorite moment from this shoot because
there are so many like weird and
wild things that happen and and you are
interacting with so many interesting
characters do you
have a favorite moment i have i mean so
many to be honest
um i love the scene
where i'm on top of the waterfall
with michael and asher
um so the characters were napoleon and
heather
and yao was like talking them into
jumping over this
this huge waterfall and you know we were
tied up so everything was safe but like
you know like to be able to be standing
over atop a waterfall and
and just being in this beautiful place
um
it was incredible it was it was such a
it was definitely a moment i'll never
forget
um yeah and just being able to just sit
down with them
one-on-one or just together because it
was just us three that day
it was um yeah it was a special time and
i'll never forget that one for sure
did you ever try to convince them to
like work work
the scene in a way that you could also
jump in or were you
like being the one to encourage them to
do it yeah
yeah jonathan can we put in like a
parachute in this scene or
um have a hand glider for some reason i
think that'll really work um
i mean yeah i would have loved to have
jumped um
i mean i say that now but like yeah as
you like look over the cliff
my legs are shaking i'm about to throw
up i say that now
in the safety of my own home but um yeah
uh if if let's put it this way if
jonathan gave me the chance to i think i
i would have taken it i think i would
hope so i also
recently watched brand new cherry flavor
which is a very good
very different kind of story and a very
different character
what's it been like for you to go from
the good place to then doing
brand new cherry flavor and nine perfect
strangers
how has it felt to play like that
combination of characters
um it's it's been great
because you know like for me anyway
um i don't want to be put into a box and
jason mendoza is a very strong character
um
definitely left his mark definitely put
florida on the map
and uh i think um yeah
moving forward as much as i i love jason
i wanted to
exercise different muscles and explore
different characters and
fortunately these people whether it be
nick and tosca from brandy cherry or
nicole and david d kelly from nine
perfect strangers they've allowed me to
do that
they've trusted me with being able to
explore and play with
with their characters was jason mendoza
a difficult character to say goodbye to
absolutely oh yeah i mean i don't know
if i'll ever say goodbye to
mr mendoza um you'll always be around
for sure
but you know that was the one that
really
you know gave me a break and that was
the one i feel that a lot of
fans a lot of people that watch
um are really um fond
of you know that character in particular
so yeah it was very hard to say goodbye
but who knows you know domino maybe give
it
ten years maybe he'll have a little
spin-off or a reunion with pillboi or
something or the whole cast
fingers crossed we'll see fingers
definitely crossed
thank you for talking to me about this
i've seen six episodes i
all these characters are so interesting
brand new cherry flavor was
a wild experience so thank you for
for the uh interesting times lately
thank you so much christina
thanks a lot